first of all let me ask you when was the
last time you guys saw each other i know
when we started the zoom you were like i
miss you and hug you
and i don't even know it's been that
long like it's been
like like 2007.
yeah like in the two the first decade of
the millennium
let's put it down it's been a long time
i miss you
can you believe it's been 20 years since
gingersnaps came out
now it's unbelievable like
it just seems like yesterday yeah it
does it seems like yes it seems like a
really long time ago and it also seems
actually like yesterday so yeah
did you think it would become such a big
cult classic
no emily and i thought we were the only
two weirdos that liked it and no one
else would ever watch this
we love this but i don't know it's
really weird there was some drama
around it at the time um
that was we just kind of vibed with it
but didn't really know that anyone else
would and thankfully
it wasn't until a few years after it
came out we did the film festival
circuit we
um the critics liked it and stuff but no
one really watched it until about two
years later i'd
i'd be somewhere and someone be like oh
my god ginger and i was like what
you thought of that right it's like how
do you
even know that how do you remember that
like i still have people to this day
coming up to me and saying
oh my gosh ginger snaps that was like my
my sister my favorite movie when we were
growing up and like it meant so much to
me
like i think it was like part of a lot
of people's sort of
formative years and like kind of a lot
of people's first horror
movie especially horror movie that dealt
with like women and women's lives
yeah so what do you think made it such a
cult classic as you said it like kind of
picked up steam a couple years later
what was it though
that made it that because those are
usually pretty special movies
yeah i mean i think i dug it just
because i was
an insecure angry teenage girl and i
hadn't really seen this
this girl portrayed uh anywhere that i
that i really dug and i think that
that's why i
vibed with her um and i think that's
just
why people eventually picked it up i
also think in small towns in canada
everyone had like the one vhs and it
went around
and people were like sharing it and that
like we go to small towns to this day
and everyone's like ginger you're like
what how did you guys reinforce to watch
this
yeah i mean i think it had that like
real darkness it really captured
like the feelings of isolation that a
lot of us have and
being an outsider when we're going
through adolescence
but it also has like this kind of absurd
sense of humor
as well which i think is like kind of
the consolation
prize of being an outsider is that like
it gives you this kind of
perspective on life and society you kind
of have this critical edge
and it's funny like let's face it like
you know a lot of the stuff that we go
through as teenagers is like the
romantic stuff and like
weird body hair stuff it's like it's
gross but it's kind of funny
right it's so true okay when was the
last time you actually sat down to watch
it and who did you watch it with
i watched it most recently i think
a year or two ago with a friend
who i think thought it was like a spoof
movie
had never like didn't really know what
it was but it was like scary movie four
or something
and and as we're watching it i'm like
chirping away blah blah and eventually i
see him get like more and more like into
it and but at the end when spoiler alert
uh bridgette kills ginger and i die he's
got like a tear in his eye i was like
are you
crying just you know it's a
it's a pretty good movie but it was
interesting to see that because
i hadn't watched it probably in about 10
15 years
and uh and it was really it was really
cool to see and
to watch with another person who had no
idea what they were going into
that's great yeah i mean it's so like
the werewolf metaphor
is just so rich like i'm not surprised
that
now of of any time they're actually like
giving it a reboot because
the times we're living through are like
the perfect crucible for
the werewolf metaphor i mean it deals
with themes of contagion
and um mental illness and isolation
and it's just really salient to what
people are experiencing right now so
yeah i hope really hope in this series
that
they sort of um make those connections
to the the context of kovid yeah
so buzzfeed did an article catherine and
said that there's still no character
like your iconic
teenage werewolf ginger what's that mean
um for you to hear that yeah i didn't
know that that's cool
um i mean it's thankfully it's it's all
down to the
the writers you know karen walton and
and john foster and the people who
visualized it and i didn't really have
to
do much ginger was such a perfect human
to watch and to just go into her skin
um i i love her for the same reasons
everyone
else does so i'm happy i'm happy she's
thought of
in that way that makes me warm and fuzzy
inside
awesome do either of you still have any
mementos that you
either stole or borrowed for a very long
time from the set
i saw my bird skull necklace
i didn't never i didn't have one oh i
don't know i don't
i don't think i ever had one maybe maybe
i think i have a ring
still i have my fangs i have my fangs
and i put them on i actually use them
for halloween i don't usually dress up
for halloween but it was so bored this
year
so i stuck them in and they still fit
they were like made by a dentist years
ago
ginger snaps cosplay i have like a white
wig
and i tried to do like the eyes and
stuff so i mean i attempted
that's awesome very good okay what do
you mentioned a little earlier
about the toronto international film
festival what do you guys remember most
about that day
i remember i was surprising totally
awkward oh sorry
go ahead go ahead
i remember being totally awkward and i
remember
there was like someone going around
asking everyone what was
in their purse and i was like terrified
to show them what was in my purse i was
like i'm not opening my person
i remember that it was kind of
terrifying and socially awkward true to
my
character i was quite socially awkward
awesome i remember
driving in a cab to like the premiere of
the festival with emily and our cab
driver we drove past electric circus and
he said he could drop us off there and
get on tv that's amazing i like to
remember that emily
yes i remember watching electric service
from my home when i was little oh my
gosh
that's amazing that you just said that
okay um
okay so i'm sure both of you have heard
that they're going to make a
gingersnaps uh into a tv series what was
your reaction when you saw that news
i was so happy i i think there is so
much there
to mine and like emily said i think a
lot of the themes
are incredibly even more relevant now
than they were then
and i think with the hype and the budget
behind it
and you know john faucet and the people
that
uh have the vision are you gonna make
something really cool like i'm
really excited to see what comes out of
that i believe that ginger and bridgette
deserve reincarnations because i just
those characters are so delightful
and weird so i'm excited
yeah i'm really excited too like i just
i really hope that
they preserve like the darkness and the
humor of the original
obviously it's going to be totally
different i can't wait to see
where the story goes and what they do
with the metaphor
and the critical edge that the original
had
um yeah it's super exciting let's say
they ask you both to make a cameo or to
be
in it what would you say of course
in a heartbeat yeah of course
yeah don't even have to think about it
for a second oh i love that
all right um have you found now that
since the movie is on amazon it can be
streamed all over the world you have a
whole new generation of people coming up
to you or talking to you or
reaching out by social media yeah
definitely
um before when conventions were possible
um a lot of kids who were not born when
we made that film or when it came out
are into it and that
i think that just speaks to the the
longevity of these like classic
themes that not a lot of other people
have really delved into
with uh with this metaphor of
menstruation as this monster invades
your body and does all these things to
you that you're not
you know really uh consenting to 100
um and just the darkness and the humor
and the
our fashion was super cool
um i just yeah i think it i think it for
the same reason that i connected with it
back in you know 1999 i think that's all
the same
people are still feeling outcasts
they're still feeling
confused and wanting to lash out at
themselves or other people and
yeah so
emily you i've read have you know
basically retired from acting do you
still do a little or
what made you hang it up all together
um i going through a divorce i like i
want i needed a more stable career
yeah i became a teacher and i love
teaching like i think
my mom was a teacher and it's always
kind of been part of
who i am but i still do a little bit of
acting most recently on
um supernatural so i was really happy i
got to be part of the last season of
that show
it's such a great show that's amazing
well listen teaching is a special
calling and we definitely need more lots
of good ones out there so that's that's
really fantastic
um i feel you two were so great together
are you going to
you know in between teaching um is there
a way that you guys can find a project
to work together again
i'd love to we actually did a really
funny movie after gingersnaps where we
played sisters again
and uh selena gomez classic film and
other cinderella story
yeah i just think periodically
throughout our lives we should just play
sisters and random stuff
yeah absolutely i can't wait till the
next one
yeah fantastic okay well we've put it
out there i feel like it's going to
happen
i think we're gonna make half happen
that's awesome well you've got to get to
the kids
and get all the food ready and all the
breakfasts you've got a puppy on your
lap so
i've got a homie here
this is it let's get it done all right
ladies thank you so much for your time
today
you